[Musik]
kann der flügelschlag eines
schmetterlings in brasilien ein tornado
in texas auslösen
aktuell 2021 wurde der präsident ist bei
einem zusammenstoß mit rebellen ermordet
eine woche später drei journalisten in
burkina faso getötet zwei davon sind
spanier
und siehe da plötzlich sprechen alle
medien über den sahel
die abgefragten regionen der welt sie
ist lena an stress und der die wüste
sahara von der großen afrikanischen
savanne trend in der sache geht es so
gewalttätig sowie im irak aber sie ist
doch mal wie viel ärmer sie hat unter
kolonialismus und wüstenbildung gelitten
und wird nun zum neuen brennpunkt des
islamischen terrorismus und diese ganz
besonderen terroristen könnten einige
der wichtigsten uran minen der welt in
ihrer gewalt bekommen
mit anderen worten sie kommen an jede
menge uran mit denen sie dann sogenannte
schmutzige bomben herstellen können
trotz alldem sie in die vereinigten
staaten
die wenigen truppen ab diese in der
regierung stationiert haben im gegenzug
wächst die zahl russischer sommer immer
stärker an
aber es gibt nur eine macht die hat
klares interesse an dieser region zeigt
frankreich was aber kümmert es
ausgerechnet frankreich was in der
sahel-zone passiert was hat der
schmetterlingseffekt mit all dem zu tun
und warum sollten wir uns dafür
interessieren was mitten in afrika ab
geht in diesem video werden wir euch das
alles erklären
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute fällt es leicht all den missbrauch
anzuprangern den das spanische imperium
oder das britische ein paar jahre in
ihren kolonien begangen haben aber seien
sehr ehrlich wenn es eine wahrlich
verbrecherische kolonialmacht gegeben
hat dann war es zweifelsohne das
imperialistische frankreich bis in den
1970 er jahre hat das frankreich fast
ein drittel der gesamten afrikanischen
bevölkerung kolonialisiert algerien mali
tschad all diese länder gehören zu den
vielen ehemaligen französischen kolonie
mehr als anderthalb jahrhunderte lang
deutete frankreich die natürlichen
ressourcen dieses kontinents aus und
hinterließ zerrüttete gesellschaften
neben den franzosen hätten die
spanischen und britischen eroberer wie
die wohlfahrt ausgesehen
das schönste ist aber auch heute selbst
20 diese politik fort aber auf eine
andere art und weise in der so genannten
cross afrika entfernt und installiert
frankreich jede diktatoren die der grund
nation am besten passen
allen voran in der sohle aber wie sieht
es eigentlich genau in der sahel zone
ausmache die frage nun als während
frankreich und islamische terrorgruppen
noch nicht genug
bald ist auch die natur nicht gut mit
den menschen im saal es ist doch
praktisch unmöglich etwas sinnvolles
anzubauen
da es häufig zu brutalen dürrn kommt
genauso wie zu gewaltigen
überschwemmungen millionen menschen
werden regelmäßig obdachlos 80 prozent
der menschen dort leben von weniger als
zwei dollar am tag
ja wir erzählen die hier politik immer
die armut auf der welt geht immer weiter
zurück doch die sahel zone ist einer der
wenigen orte an denen sie im gegenteil
wächst ohne hoffnung auf besserung
ganz im gegenteil wir reden hier nicht
über eine kleine region schau dir diese
karte an ums leben mehr als 300
millionen menschen in staaten wie
burkina faso mali niger tschad und
vielen anderen um die eine vorstellung
davon zu geben wie gross dieser region
ist die entfernung in der sahel zone von
der ost- bis an die westküste ist im
grunde die gleiche wie von deutschland
bis an die westgrenze china
diese zone war schon immer haben aber
jetzt kommt zu all dem elend auch noch
die gewalt hinzu tausende von menschen
sterben jedes jahr durch die hand
verschiedener terrorgruppen sowohl al
qaida als auch der islamische staat
haben hier fuß gefasst und ihre präsenz
wird immer bedeutender
das hat nun auch frankreich gemacht
[Musik]
frankreich werde zusätzliche truppen und
extremisten in afrika sahel zu bekämpfen
heute sind mehr als 5000 russischen
soldaten in der zone stationiert die
euro führt seit acht jahren die
operation - mal durch um die situation
in mali zu stabilisieren die europäische
union engagiert sich mit zwei
ausbildungsmission und vielen millionen
euro an humanitärer hilfe aber bis jetzt
hat nichts davon geholfen inzwischen
schenken jedoch auch die türkei und
russland dieser region immer mehr
aufmerksamkeit
die frage lautet also was unternimmt
frankreich ist das was in der sahel-zone
passiert wirklich von so großer
bedeutung für die weltpolitik heute da
wir diese fragen beantworten und zwar
wie immer durch einen schnellen blick in
die geschichte
das dreieck des bösen wäre die salzen
ein land wäre sie gemessen an der
bevölkerungszahl das viertgrößte land
der welt aber wie du dir vorstellen
kannst ist diese region alles andere als
homogen
es gibt eine menge ungleichheit und
große unterschiede wenn wir den
westlichen mit dem östlichen teil
vergleichen deshalb werden wir uns im
heutigen video auf fürst länder in der
zentralen und westlichen zone
konzentrieren
burkina faso mali mauretanien und niger
diese länder haben zwei dinge gemeinsam
seid 2014 sind sie teil der g15 allianz
ehemals französische kolonie sind sie
nun gescheiterte diktaturen aber was
eingeschaltete diktatur nun diktaturen
in denen der diktator nicht einmal die
kontrolle über sein gesamtes land hat es
gibt gebiete die von stellen und vor
terrorgruppen beherrscht werden
aber als ob das alles nicht schon übel
genug wäre gibt es in der sahel zone
eine noch die schlimmere region lebt
burma oder einfach das dreieck des bösen
dürfe ein blick auf diese karte wie du
sehen kannst sprechen wir über das
dreiländereck zwischen burkina faso
niger und mali in den letzten jahren ist
ist zum epi zentrum die headis tischer
gewalt geworden plus drogen menschen und
waffenhandel und das ruft öner auf den
plan
frankreich verstärkt die balkan truppe
auf 5100 man um sich weiter auf das
dreiländereck mali burkina faso niger zu
konzentrieren
aber warum hat vor allem frankreich ein
solches interesse an dieser region nun
die hunderte lang war frankreich dort
die wichtigste kolonialmacht aber seien
wir ehrlich auch 60 jahre nach dem ende
der kolonialzeit hatte die kommission
ihre kolonien nie ganz aufgegeben und du
weißt sicher dass frankreich einer der
führenden atommächte der welt ist denen
nicht nur über atomwaffen verfügt
sondern auch weltweit nummer zwei auf
der liste der länder mit den meisten
atomkraftwerken ist
70 prozent des französischen stroms ist
atomstrom
tja und woher bekommt frankreich das
uran um so viele atomkraftwerke zu
betreiben
ganz einfach aus ländern wie gabun und
tschad beides ehemalige französische
kolonie gut du sagst jetzt leicht wo ist
das problem
das ist doch eine rein geschäftliche
beziehungen zwischen souveränen ländern
tja pustekuchen die realität ist die
folgende erfolgreich selbst in seinem
urahn lieferländern diktatoren nach
gutdünken ein und ab alles nur um die
uran versorgung zu garantieren um die
reine vorstellung zu geben
frankreichs einfluss in afrika ist so
gewaltig dass sogar die währung die in
den meisten ländern der salz sole
verwendet wird der csv an die
französische staatskasse gebunden ist
ich kann jetzt schon sagen dass sich das
in zukunft ändern könnte denn die
westafrikanischen länder erwägen den
wechsel zu ihrer eigenen währung namens
eco aber bis dahin sind auch die
banksysteme der länder die der saison
verwenden von paris abhängig und ich
weiß was du willst denkst aber mal
frankreich hat doch nichts verbrochen
was auch zum beispiel die usa nicht
getan haben nun ja du hast recht aber
wie wir auf diesen kanal immer sagen der
teufel steckt im detail
der große unterschied zwischen
frankreich und jeder anderen
kolonialmacht liegt in der fokussierung
zum beispiel erstreckte sich die
britische kolonialherrschaft in indien
in jedem winkel des landes klar die
dritten waren die herren aber sie
kümmerten sich auch um den bau von
eisenbahnen schulen und die sicherheit
in allen städten frankreich jedoch in
viel konzentrierter vor
was ich damit meine nun schaute diese
karte was du hier siehst sind die
eisenbahnstrecken im heutigen afrika die
meisten von ihnen wurden in der
kolonialzeit gebaut wie du sehen kannst
haben die bahnstrecken die sich im
westlichen zahlen befinden eines
gemeinsam sie gehen von der küste aus
und führen zu den großen
rohstoffvorkommen
sie dienen also nur dazu so schnell wie
möglich zu den rohstoffen zu kommen sie
einzusammeln und an wieder in die großen
städte zurückzukehren
deshalb ging es im süden der seine
zugverbindungen und im norden nicht im
grunde ging es den französischen
kolonialherren nur darum dienen zu
kontrollieren
der rest des landes hat sie nicht die
bohne interessiert all dies erklärt
warum es sich beim letzten land der welt
in dem die sklaverei offiziell
abgeschafft wurde ausgerechnet um
mauretanien handelt immer als eine
französische kolonie bis 1981 war es in
diesem land vollkommen legal sklaven zu
halten selbst heute gibt es dort noch
menschliche mastbetriebe das heißt
farmen auf denen frauen gemästet werden
und traditionellen schönheitsideal zu
entsprechen
[Musik]
aber die franzosen sind nicht die
einzigen teilnehmer der region ist so
kommen dürren und das wachstum der
wüsten die sahara lese ich ja du ja
weiter aus nach angaben der uno steigt
die temperatur in dieser region 1,5 mal
schneller als im rest der welt das fazit
abgesehen von den uran und gold minen
wird fast das gesamte gebiet der sahel
zone von lokalen stämmen kontrolliert
die tuareg zum beispiel sind einer jener
nomadenstämme die seit jahren ist einen
eigenen staat kämpfen und das ist nur
eine von vielen ethnischen gruppen die
sich seit jahren dort gegenseitig
bekämpfen aber die frage ist doch warum
begeht uns dass gerade jetzt so zu
beunruhigen warum steht europa plötzlich
so viele soldaten in dieser region was
genau hat sich verändert nun wir werden
uns das mal genauer ansehen
[Musik]
der lybische krieg es gibt noch einen
weiteren bereich in dem sich frankreich
von allen anderen mächten unterscheidet
nämlich die art und weise wie sie krieg
führen während die vereinigten staaten
uns so ein dollar dafür aufbringen um
die länder die sich direkt besetzen auch
wieder aufzubauen ist frankreich viel
pragmatischer der krieg im irak hat das
weiße haus zum beispiel mehr als 700
milliarden dollar gekostet das meiste
geht versucht darauf das land nach dem
sturz von saddam hussein wieder
aufzubauen und ob das gelungen ist steht
auf einem anderen blatt aber was du
schon in lybien trägt genau das
gegenteil
der libyenkrieg kostet die franzosen
etwas mehr als eine milliarde dollar
eigentlich ein schnäppchen und wie war
es möglich dass dieser krieg die
franzosen so billig kommt ganz einfach
war die franzosen ankamen bedarf die
stürzten die ölfelder sicherten und
wieder gehen
katy er diese gegend ist ein echtes
pulverfass die bringen sich hier alle
gegenseitig um sogar da ich möchte hier
kräftig mit ok lass mal sehen schon
polen sag mal gibt es denn genau dort wo
die ölvorkommen liegen auch noch der
osten nein ausgezeichnet dann ist auch
alles in butter
unsere arbeit ist getan lasst uns
einfach hingehen und warum spreche ich
jetzt über die kriege in libyen
erinnerst du dich noch daran dass am
anfang des videos über den
schmetterlingseffekt gesprochen haben
auch in dieser geschichte gibt es viele
punkte
die miteinander verbunden sind gaddafi
hatte eine der besten armee in ganz
afrika und rate mal wo deren ganzes
arsenal an die waffen gelandet
was aushalten aus libyen verstärken die
rebellen in mali
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es in mainz
vielleicht guerilla aber es waren
ziemlich mies ausgeführte tobias
plötzlich wurden alle konflikte in mali
zu einem problem für die ganze welt denn
die tuaregs sind eigentlich ein berner
volk in der wüste sahara
sie sind über sechs länder verteilt und
eines davon ist molly schade also mal
eine andere karte an wie du hier sehen
kannst wird die nord süd teilung marlies
sehr deutlich wenn wir uns auf die em
konzentrieren
die hauptstadt bamako liegt im süden
während die hälfte des nördlichen teils
von den touareg bewohnt wird die
trauerkarten schon mehrmals versucht
ihre unabhängigkeit zu erlangen
bislang ohne erfolg dann verfügten sie
jedoch über libysche waffen und ihre
ansprüche durchzusetzen
aber das ist noch nicht alles denn neben
dem separatismus hatte der krieg in mali
einen weiteren protagonisten den
jihadismus ein radikalisierter teile
ausländischen beschloss von nun an die
scharia in der gesamten region
durchzusetzen
wir sprechen zum beispiel voran sagt
diene einer touareg moslemgruppierung
der em jahr 2012 gegründet wurde
hinzu gesellten sich die al kaida im
islamischen maghreb die bewegung für
einheit und sie hat in westafrika und
eine weitere fraktion mit den überaus
sympathischen namen die mit blut
unterschreiben kurz gesagt genau jener
menschenschlag der lieber nicht in
besitz von waffen sein sollte im jahr
2012 eskalierte die situation dann mit
unglaublicher geschwindigkeit innerhalb
weniger monate hatten die separatisten
bereits die kontrolle über den norden
des landes in die regierung in bamako
war machtlos
und wer kam zur rettung überraschungen
frankreich beteiligt sich am kampf gegen
die islamisten in mali sagte hundt am 11
januar 2013 bat die regierung war ließ
höchstpersönlich ihren ehemaligen
kolonialherren darum militärisch zu
intervenieren und noch am selben tag
flogen kampfjets mit der trikolore auf
den flügeln über die salze die
preisfrage lautet jedoch auch die
französische regierung es denn auch
wirklich geschafft hat den mit
rassistischen terror in der region ein
ende zu bereiten und warum stimmte sie
eigentlich so schnell für den
kriegseinsatz welche besonderen gründe
hatte sie sich um die sache zu kümmern
aufgepasst fast unlösbare passen wo acht
jahren im jahr 2003 war die malische
regierung frankreich um hilfe und ist
halt dich fest seitdem ist die
französische armee immer noch in mali
präsent als folge nimmt die
antifranzösische stimmung in mali immer
weiter zu und auch in frankreich ist
immer mehr ablehnung gegen diesen krieg
du wirst dich also mit der recht fragen
warum frankreich dann immer noch dort
ist stecken hinter frankreichs
militärintervention etwa noch andere
interessen als die schnellstmögliche
stabilisierung der betroffenen länder
also weißt du noch was historisch
gesehen frankreichs top interessen in
der sahel zone war rohstoffe
denn sollten islamische kräfte die
kontrolle über strategische vorkommen
erlangen könnte frankreich plötzlich mit
leeren händen dastehen
ohne das öl aus dem tschad das gold
wallis oder das uran aus dem niger bei
letzterem kommt noch ein weiteres
problem hinzu
viele befürchten dass dieses uran in den
händen von dschihadisten landen könnte
könnten sie also atomwaffen herstellen
sicherlich nicht die herstellung von
atombomben erfordert eine primitive
terrorgruppe praktisch unerreichbares
level an technischem know how
allerdings könnten sie sogenannte
schmutzige bomben bauen bomben die uran
enthalten und die damit bei ihrer
explosion alles in ihrer umgebung
versorgen können es wurde das ziel
darüber spekuliert wie hoch das
tatsächliche risiko ist dass solche
schmutzigen wochen darstellen können
fakt ist jedoch dass ist im zweifelsfall
einfach besser ist uranminen zuschüssen
better safe than sorry
[Applaus]
frankreich ist uran mine in eger
offensichtlich hat nun auch im
elysée-palast vom schmetterlingseffekt
gehört und weiß nur zu gut dass es
stabilität in einem abgelegenen teil der
welt sich auch direkt und desaströse im
französischen mutterland auswirken
könnte
zur katastrophe braucht es jedoch keine
schmutzigen bomben
denn eines habe ich den dieses video
nicht verraten die sahel zone ist eine
demografische zeitbombe
es wird zum beispiel geschätzt dass sich
die bevölkerung des niger bis 2050 fast
ihr machen könnte auf fast 100 millionen
menschen
wir haben es also mit einer region zu
tun die immer ärmer und gewalttätiger
wird und in der immer mehr menschen
leben und all das bedeutet für europa
eine neue generation svh allen
gewaltigen ausmaßes denn wenn du aus
mali oder dem tschad kommst welches
europäische ziele
würdest du am liebsten sehen klar in
deutschland gibt es die meiste knete
aber ein land dessen sprache du bereits
beherrscht wäre auch nicht übel oder
und was noch viel wichtiger ist ein land
in dem du viele leute aus seiner
community oder wenn du glück hast sogar
deinen kurse dritten grades treffen
wirst so dass du dich gar nicht so oder
nicht anpassen muss tja und das wäre
dann halt frankreich laut den zahlen des
französischen instituts für statistik
und wirtschaftsstudien wurden mehr als
46 prozent der in frankreich lebenden
bekannten auf den afrikanischen
kontinent geboren wo diese daten
umfassen nicht einmal die illegale
migration und wenn man dann noch die
bedrohung frankreichs durch islamische
terror berücksichtigt da steht man
schnell warum sie so besorgt über die
kontrolle der migrationsströme sind die
frage ist also was unternehmen die
franzosen um diese neue völkerwanderung
zu verhindern nun auf der einen seite
haben wir eine reihe von
militäreinsätzen zunächst startet
frankreich 2013 die operation war eine
intervention in mali die vom
un-sicherheitsrat geblickt wurde
beteiligt waren daran 3500 französische
soldaten ein jahr später wichtig noch
weil der anti-terror-operation balkan
5100 französische soldaten und 405 aus
anderen ländern im jahr 2020 auf die
europäische union eine taskforce namens
all diese operation haben auch von der
grund sparen hilfe der usa profitiert
aber sein damit ehrlich frankreich hat
im weißen haus nie erlaubt sich zu sehr
einzumischen von anfang an war klar dass
bei all diesen operationen sahel der
élysée-palast den ton angibt denn die
oberste priorität frankreichs ist noch
immer seinem hegemonialen einfluss in
dieser region zu behalten und das letzte
was in dieser hinsicht brauchen sind
konkurrenten es bleibt also die frage ob
all diese militäreinsätze überhaupt
wirkung zeigen nun ja durchaus aber eine
ganz andere als du erwartet hast
frankreich und die vereinigten staaten
verschlimmern die sicherheitslage in
westafrika in diesem stadium scheint es
dass eine rein militärische lösung nicht
ausreichend wird daher sei die türkei
ihren moment gekommen und schickte
medikamente und masken gegen korona in
den niger und dem tschad motiv einfluss
in der region
[Musik]
tja und plötzlich erinnert frankreichs
an strategie von hochgradig orientierten
militärintervention gehen sie zu einer
zuckerbrot und peitsche strategie über
peitsche für den pianisten und zucker
brot für loyale regierungen bin zum
beispiel das projekt der großen grünen
mauer
dabei handelt es sich um ein projekt bei
dem ein sehr langer streifen aus wäldern
und farmen angelegt wird und die
wüstenbildung zu verhindern dieses
projekt wurde bereits im jahr 2007
gestartet aber kaum mit geldmitteln
ausgestattet das ergebnis es hat nicht
funktioniert doch anfang 2021 als
frankreich die felle davon schwimmen
finden sie plötzlich an geld in das
projekt zu pumpen und sie haben wirklich
keine kosten und mühen gescheut
[Musik]
great green wurde hält über 14
milliarden dollar zur wieder begrünung
der sahel zone unter anderem von
frankreich oder weltbank aber jetzt bist
du an der reihe
denkst du dass diese neue französische
strategie neue migrationswellen
verhindern wird was denkst du würde
passieren wenn frankreich seine truppen
von einem tag auf den anderen abziehen
würde und kennst du andere beispiele
dafür wie kolonialpolitik weiterhin
ihren einfluss auf die heutige welt hat
teilt eure meinung bitte die immer mit
uns und auch einen anderen im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja gibt uns bitte ein
leid geteilt dessen freundin und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal auch zu
abonnieren macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]